[Music]
in the new movie uh girl most likely uh
you you have a you have a sex scene with
with kristin wig is that right yes it is
and and uh i'm just curious you know i'm
always fascinated by this kind of thing
because a i'm a perv and b right i don't
understand the acting process but if
you're going to have a sex scene with
somebody
you kind of have to get to know them you
kind of know and unfortunately i think
they were kind enough to try and
schedule that on the latter half of the
shooting schedule but through some
things there were some weather issues
and uh through series of events we got
pushed to like the third day and this is
very awkward for me because at this
point kristen wing's a huge star i'm
some random kid walking in this movie
going like hey i'm darren i'm uh i'm
gonna put my face in and around the area
of your genitals
now if you're okay with that um it
sounds like one of your songs actually
yeah exactly exactly i guess material is
always coming
thank you that's going to be great in
italian yeah
at the grammys yeah but she but she was
probably cool about it i just think that
was that's going to be a very expensive
it's it's always people always ask
actors like oh you know you know this
when there's like kissing scenes or
things it's it's actually weird and
because there's a thousand people in the
room looking at you're like oh this is
instantly not sexy so i bet when you're
doing a sex scene there's like hundreds
of thousands of people oh yeah yeah i
think i've seen you there i'm outside
the lot i'm always
i'm always dressed up as a
cameraman sitting behind a newspaper
with holes in it
conan uh
no okay you know this is this is full
circle we did a television show together
that's what we did you did a tv show
again my first gig out in los angeles
ever was with this beautiful woman and
she was saying don't you touch her oh i
know exactly
all here
um so this is such a crazy collection
well and he did the same thing he just
did to you he showed up at comic-con and
and asked for stood in line for an
autograph for a show and said will you
sign my parking pass i just auditioned
for your show on friday and on monday
morning he was there at the table read
and we went were you just yeah i didn't
know that i got the part yeah this is
how big of a freako nerd i am i was at
comic-con and i just auditioned i
literally drove from com from the
audition to that i was like oh
eastwood's having a signing how funny
would it be if i got my parking pass and
he stood in this really long line and as
and got his parking permit signed and
then he was there at the table read on
monday and he'd gotten the job it was
crazy you know what's funny that
actually didn't get the job i've just
been lying this whole time
and i just showed up and this is just a
season you're on a tour here at warner
brothers and just stepped off yeah
that's it it sounds like he's stalking
you rebecca
so that thing yeah exactly